The polynomial reducability of one
problem to another is a relation,
much like the at most relation that
you've seen since elementary school.
And while it doesn't have
all the same properties,
it does have the important
property of transitivity.
Like the traditional at most sign for
integers or real numbers,
the polynomial reducability sign is
transitive, meaning that if A is
reducable to B and B is reducible to C,
then A is reducible to C.
For example, we've seen how independent
set is reducible to vertex cover, and
I claim that vertex cover is reducible
to Hamiltonian path, a problem closely
related to the traveling salesman
problem, and from these facts,
it follows that independent set
is reducible to Hamiltonian path.
Let's take a look at
the proof of this theorem.
We'll let M be the program
that reduces A to B,
and we'll let N be the program
that reduces B to C.
To turn an instance of the problem
A into an instance of the problem C
we just pass it through M and
then pass that result through N.
This whole process can be thought of
as another computable function, R.
Note that like M and N,
R is polynomial-time.
Thus x is in A if, and
only if, M of x is in B.
Remember, M implements that reduction.
And m of x is in B if and
only if N of M of x is in C because
N implements that reduction.
The composition of N and
M is the reduction R so
overall we have the x is in A if and
only if R is in C, just as we want.